on va commencer merci monsieur le
ministre vous êtes notre
dernière personne personnalité à être
auditionnée par notre commission
d'enquête puisque nous avons commencé
ces auditions à la fin du mois de
janvier qu'on a voulu on a commencé par
tous les anciens ministres qui depuis
2012 avait eu sous le responsabilité
soit la transition écologique et le
logement ou le logement et on a voulu
terminer par les trois ministres
aujourd'hui qui sont en exercice et donc
on a auditionné la semaine dernière
Agnès panier renacher Christophe Béchu
et donc on termine avec vous ce cycle
des auditions de notre commission
d'enquête qui ont également été
ponctuées par un certain nombre de
déplacements dans l'Isère chez monsieur
le rapporteur dans les Alpes-Maritimes
mais également à Bruxelles et donc je
pense qu'on a fait autant de faire
possible un tour très très complet un
spectre très très large sur tout ce qui
touche à la politique publique en
matière de rénovation énergétique donc
merci à vous de votre présence vous
occupez cette fonction depuis le mois de
juillet 2022 auparavant vous avez été
notamment président de la rue de 2017 à
2022 et maire de Clichy-sous-Bois de
2011 à 2022 la semaine dernière la
première ministre a présenté ce que le
gouvernement retenait des travaux du
Conseil national de la refondation
logement ces annonces ont été jugées
très décevantes par beaucoup et pour ce
qui concerne la commission d'enquête
aujourd'hui au regard des réflexions
présentées par le groupe consacré à la
transition écologique des logements qui
avaient formulé nombre de propositions
intéressantes et pertinentes renouveler
les annonces sur le déploiement de
France rénov et des accompagnateurs ou
indiquer le dépôt d'une proposition de
loi sur le prêt avance rénovation dont
une des centaines seulement a été
accordée c'est vraiment vous me
l'accorderez peu de choses quant à
porter le nombre de rénovations
performantes à 200 000 en 2024 grâce au
renforcement de ma prime rénove c'est
certes nécessaires mais cela semble
encore manquer de perspective quand la
stratégie nationale bas carbone en
programmé plus de 500 000 en moyenne et
700 000 dans les années à venir de fait
depuis 2022 le sujet de la rénovation
énergétique des logements n'a pas quitté
le cœur de l'actualité il y a une vraie
effervescence sur le sujet les Français
y sont désormais fortement sensibilisés
mais il se pose encore beaucoup de
questions et son prix parfois par le
doute certains points sont positifs
comme le cadre défini pour les années à
venir par la loi climat et résilience
le réel succès numérique de ma prime
rénove qui montre une dynamique de
rénovation mais il y a vous le savez de
vrais défis à relever sur lesquels nous
voudrions vous entendre cet après-midi
pour massifier les rénovations
performantes et surtout pour créer un
véritable cadre de confiance nos
concitoyens ont l'impression que le
diagnostic de performance énergétique le
fameux DPE a été rendu opposable avant
même que sa fiabilité ne soit garantie
et que les professionnels ne soient à
même de le mettre en oeuvre de manière
satisfaisante les exemples abondent de
logement ayant obtenu une notation
différente selon le diagnostiqueur voire
de logements dont la notation a été
dégradée après des travaux de rénovation
sans compter la difficulté son
application au logement construit avant
1948 qui inquiète énormément tous les
défenseurs du patrimoine et des paysages
vis-à-vis des entreprises nos
concitoyens redoutent les fraudes et les
malfaçons dans ce contexte le label RGE
reconnu garant de l'environnement
semblent décourager nombre d'entreprises
sans apporter devrait garanties par
ailleurs lorsqu'ils veulent effectuer
des travaux nos concitoyens sont
confrontés à un maquis d'aide et de
conseils parfois contradictoires ou
inappropriés qui décourage bon nombre
d'entre eux nous entendons un grand
besoin depuis le début de nos auditions
de simplification de neutralité et de
proximité nous avons eu l'impression
dans nos déplacements quand voulant
accélérer les rénovations
à travers ma prime rénov ou les C2E on a
déconnecté cette politique des acteurs
de terrain artisans ou collectivités ce
qui facilite les fraudes qui sont
souvent mal détectés ou puni en raison
de la fragmentation des contrôles si le
parc social est prêt mais manque
aujourd'hui de fonds propres pour
accélérer dans le parc privé il y a au
moins trois difficultés
en raison des limites actuelles du DPE
il y a de vrais interrogations sur son
impact sur le marché de l'immobilier et
la possibilité que nombre de logements
soient retirés du marché locatif ou que
des propriétaires subissent des
préjudices patrimoniaux importants tout
particulièrement dans l'ancien ensuite
le calendrier de la loi climat
résilience semble peu adapter au temps
nécessaire et au mode de décision
dans les copropriétés plus
particulièrement comment rendre les
copropriétaires solidaires facilité la
prise de décision et malgré tout prendre
en compte ces spécificités dans le
calendrier la troisième difficulté que
nous avons pu identifier et que nous
avons entendu au cours des auditions
c'est celle du financement financement
collectif au niveau des collectivités
mais aussi financement individuel en
raison des difficultés à cumuler les
aides à réduire le reste à charge et à
accéder à des prêts adaptés aux besoins
je sais que le gouvernement travaille
sur tous ces sujets je souhaite ainsi
que l'ensemble des membres présents ici
que vous puissiez nous en dire plus
aujourd'hui avant de vous laisser la
parole monsieur le ministre pour
répondre à ses premières questions donc
il me reviennent de vous indiquer que
cette position est diffusée en direct et
en différé sur le site internet du Sénat
et qu'un compte-rendu sera publié je
dois également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage de votre commission d'enquête
serait passible des peines prévues aux
articles
434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de 3 ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de
45000 euros à 100000 € d'amende aussi
monsieur le ministre je vous invite donc
à prêter serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je ne jure
je vous en remercie et donc je vous
laisse la parole pour répondre à ces
premières questions faire votre propos
introductif ensuite on laissera la
parole bien évidemment à Monsieur de
rapporteur et à l'ensemble des membres
de notre commission d'enquête qui
assistent à votre audition
merci beaucoup madame la présidente
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs tout à l'heure
tout d'abord pardon je tiens à saluer le
travail conséquent de votre commission
et comme vous l'avez rappelé j'ai
compris que cette audition de plusieurs
mois de plusieurs déplacements s'achève
aujourd'hui avec cette audition je
n'oserais avoir loutre finance de dire
que vous avez gardé le meilleur pour la
fin parce que j'en suis j'en n'en suis
pas absolument certain mais en tout cas
je ferai de de mon mieux le sujet de la
rénovation énergétique qui est un sujet
comme vous l'avez rappelé à Fort en jeu
et il connaît aujourd'hui chez nos
concitoyens une visibilité importante et
je crois qu'il faut s'en réjouir c'est
un sujet important pour le climat
évidemment mais également pour la vie de
nos concitoyens en particulier les plus
fragiles en termes de pouvoir d'achat
mais également de santé
dans ce contexte d'urgence climatique
couplé à une période d'inflation encore
soutenue il ne faut pas opposer fin du
mois et fin du monde en un mot l'urgence
environnementale est et surtout une
urgence sociale aussi si le sujet
dispose de cette visibilité aujourd'hui
s'il est désormais une préoccupation
pour beaucoup de nos concitoyens je
crois que c'est à mettre au crédit de la
politique menée depuis 2017
en effet quoi qu'on en pense le DPE
opposable a fait de la performance
environnementale un critère prioritaire
dans le choix d'un logement le lancement
de ma prime rénov a installé la
rénovation au cœur du débat public il a
fait entrer les cogestes dans tous nos
foyers c'est un premier succès essentiel
qui nous expose et nous oblige d'autant
plus que les résultats sont scrutés
comme par vous aujourd'hui avec une
attention constante et c'est légitime
s'agissant des résultats je défends haut
et fort la dynamique historique initié
sur le quinquennat précédent et sur
laquelle nous pouvons nous appuyer pour
accélérer ce bilan est positif quelques
chiffres depuis son lancement en 2020 ma
prime rénov a permis d'aider plus de 1,5
millions de Français à se lancer dans un
projet de travaux de rénovation
énergétique pour plus de 6 milliards
d'euros engagés
5,6 milliards d'euros engagés pardon de
bénéficiaires sur 3 de ma prime rénov
dispose de ressources modestes ou très
modestes quand le crédit d'impôt en
vigueur jusqu'en 2019 bénéficiait pour
près de moitié à 45% des ménages des des
cils 9 et 10 de revenus sur les dossiers
payés depuis le début de l'année le gain
énergétique annuel moyen par logement
est en hausse de 30% par rapport à 2021
et 80% supérieur aux gains constaté sur
l'ancien cite
depuis 2020 plus de 185000 rénovations
globales ont été financés à travers
notamment ma prime rénov sérénité dont
près de la moitié correspondent à des
sorties de passoire
s'agissant de l'habitat collectif les
objectifs de ma prime rénov copropriété
ont été dépassés en 2022 avec plus de
25000 logements rénovés dont 10 000
seulement en 2021 les aides ont été
relevées en début d'année pour atteindre
un objectif d'au moins 40 000 logements
en 2023 si les volumes restent donc
relativement modestes et vous l'avez
rappelé la dynamique est très positive
et nous la soutenons activons activement
sans réduire l'ambition des projets dont
le gain énergétique est supérieur à 50%
en moyenne bref les résultats sont là
pour autant rappeler ses réussites
concrètes tangibles ne veut pas dire que
tout est parfait loin de là je comprends
que d'autres constats interrogent que
des attentes subsistent dans le débat
public notamment face à la nécessité
d'accélérer encore pour atteindre nos
objectifs de 2030 c'est la raison pour
laquelle plusieurs chantiers d'ampleur
sont en cours
notre feuille de route est claire pour
aider toujours plus efficacement les
ménages à rénover leur logement nous
avons deux priorités l'accompagnement
l'accompagnement est essentiel pour que
les rénovations soient adaptées aux
besoins et soit plus ambitieuses c'est
le sens du partenariat avec les
collectivités pour inscrire France Renov
dans la durée et renforcer la couverture
du territoire avec un objectif d'un
guichet par EPCI d'ici 2025 inscrit dans
la feuille de route du gouvernement
la refonte de notre système d'aide en
deux piliers comme nous l'avons annoncé
hier avec Christophe bichut et Agnès
panier rue nachées pour le rendre plus
lisible et mieux répondre à nos
objectifs de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre
de la consommation énergétique et de
l'éradication des passe-parts thermiques
voire deux piliers donc un pilier
efficacité pour maintenir un socle
d'aide par geste centrée sur
l'installation de système de chauffage
décarboné et accompagner la sortie des
énergies fossiles un pilier performance
pour créer une voie réservée unique
vraiment incitative pour la rénovation
énergétique permettant d'atteindre des
étiquettes ABC du DPE en une ou deux
étapes
ce parcours sera systématiquement suivi
par un accompagnateur Renov dont la
prestation sera couverte intégralement
pour les ménages les plus modestes grâce
à un nouveau programme de ces deux œufs
national doté de 300 millions d'euros
c'est vers ce parcours que seront
orientés toutes les passoires thermiques
auxquelles il est indispensable
d'apporter un traitement global
s'agissant plus spécifiquement des
copropriétés privées dont vous avez
parlé nous nous appuierons sur la
dynamique très positive engagée à
travers ma prime rénov copropriété qui
fera partie intégrante du pilier
performant comme pour les maisons
individuelles nous ferons évoluer le
dispositif pour atteindre en une ou deux
étapes les étiquettes les plus
performantes du DPE le calendrier de
mise en oeuvre de ces évolutions sera
adaptée et plus progressive pour tenir
compte du temps nécessaire au projet
collectif et sécurisé ceux déjà en cours
de discussion ou de montage
enfin les évolutions des barèmes en
discussion viseront à répondre à
certaines problématiques spécifiques je
pense notamment au cas des propriétés
des copropriétés fragiles voire en
difficulté qu'il soit dans un dispositif
d'OPA de plantes sauvegarde car la
réalisation de travaux de rénovation
lourdes permettant de réduire les
factures et la bonne réponse
structurelle pour résorber les
difficultés financières des copropriétés
et des copropriétaires
deuxième
adaptation l'adaptation des critères des
aides aux impossibilités techniques ou
contrainte architecturales notamment
dans les centres anciens j'en profite
pour dire également un mot sur la
question du parc locatif privé qui est
qui représente plus de 2/3 de l'habitat
collectif sur laquelle nous pourrons
revenir mais sur lequel il est
extrêmement important d'avancer les
propriétaires bailleurs disposent
aujourd'hui des mêmes aides que les
propriétaires
occupants
certains dispositifs spécifiques leur
sont dédiés par exemple le crédit le
déficit foncier je crois que notre enjeu
prioritaire est celui de la mobilisation
de tous l'écosystème pour faire levier
sur les moyens existants et c'est le
sens du comité des partenaires que j'ai
installé sur ce sujet mi-avril et que je
réunirai une nouvelle fois au début du
mois de juillet
s'agissant enfin du parc social je
commencerai par souligner l'ambition
pleinement partagée avec le mouvement
HLM pour que le secteur prenne toute sa
part à nos objectifs de décor bonation
d'ici 2030 la transition écologique sera
un axe structurant du pacte de confiance
que nous concluons sur lequel nous
travaillons d'arrache-pied à la demande
de la première ministre avec les
bailleurs les travaux menés sur la
trajectoire de rénovation sont fructueux
permettent de définir le chemin qu'il
convient de décliner au sein des groupes
mais je sais évidemment les
interrogations quant au financement de
cet effort sans précédent
la première ministre a annoncé la
semaine dernière lors de la restitution
du CNR la création du dispositif seconde
vie pour permettre le rechargement des
avantages fiscaux de la production neuve
lors d'opération de rénovation lourde le
succès de l'expérimentation lancée cette
année et dont les premiers projets
déposés sont en cours d'instruction
laisse présager une belle dynamique avec
un objectif de 10000 logements
réhabilités chaque année dans le cadre
du dispositif second de vie au delà de
cette annonce le pacte de confiance
prévoit un dispositif d'aide à la
rénovation énergétique
à concevoir de telle sorte qu'il
bénéficie en priorité au bailleur ou
groupe dont la situation financière ou
patrimoniale le nécessite le plus
pour conclure ce propos liminaire je
m'arrêterai sur quatre conditions
transversales de réussite de la feuille
de route que je viens d'essayer de vous
esquisser première condition
l'implication des collectivités
territoriales tout d'abord et la bonne
coordination de leurs actions avec celle
de l'État s'agissant de la rénovation
des logements je pense notamment à leur
rôle indispensable en matière
d'accompagnement à travers France Renov
ou par la distribution des aides à la
pierre déléguées qui constitueront le
socle du pilier performance de demain
deuxième condition la mobilisation
accrue des sources de financement
privées en complément des moyens publics
ciblés prioritairement sur nos
concitoyens les plus modestes nous
menons avec les banques des travaux pour
des déployer davantage l'offre de prêt
réglementé d'autres propositions
complémentaires et innovantes comme
issue du CNR logement de créer une
banque de la rénovation sont à
investiguer avec un temps attention mais
nous aurons peut-être l'occasion d'en
reparler enfin
la structuration pas enfin mais ensuite
la structuration des filières car nous
ne pourrons relever les défis devant
nous sans l'engagement de nos
entreprises et de nos artisans le point
d'équilibre à trouver est subtil
notamment sur le débat sur les
évolutions du label RGE pour simplifier
les lourdeurs administratives tout en
renforçant les exigences de qualifier de
qualifier de qualité pardon notamment
par la formation
enfin cette fois-ci c'est un vrai enfin
la lutte déterminée contre la fraude car
il en va de la bonne gestion des deniers
publics et de la crédibilité de notre
politique auprès des Français la fraude
ne doit jamais être un argument contre
de le développement de notre action et
les moyens que nous y consacrons pour
atteindre nos objectifs
voilà Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs les principaux éléments dont
je voulais vous faire part et je suis je
vais l'essayer en tout cas à votre
disposition
merci monsieur le ministre pour ces
propos introductifs je compte bien sûr
sur l'ensemble de nos collègues je pense
qu'ils vont vous poser un certain nombre
de questions et on va commencer bien sûr
par le rapporteur
merci merci madame la Présidente merci
Monsieur le Ministre déjà pour ces pour
ces éléments
moi j'avais effectivement quelques
quelques questions et puis et puis
remarque et notamment par rapport
peut-être aussi aux annonces du coup qui
ont été faites quoi ont été faites hier
sur la question de la rénovation de la
rénovation thermique donc peut-être
aussi des questions peut-être de
précision par rapport à ce qui peut être
annoncé
et peut-être d'abord c'est vrai que vous
l'avez bien je pense bien formulé en
fait sur le fait que sur en matière de
rénovation thermique on voit qu'on a
trois gros blocs quoi trois
problématiques un petit peu différentes
avec
l'habitation individuelle et privée
le collectif est privé et plutôt en
termes de de copropriété qui est du coup
une autre une autre problématique et
puis le collectif et le logement social
et donc là sur lequel on peut voilà on
peut distinguer aussi d'autres d'autres
d'autres aspects d'autres problématiques
en tout cas pour arriver justement à la
fois assez rapidement et à massifier
justement la rénovation la rénovation
thermique
sur le sur l'individuel où on peut se
dire que c'est peut-être le plus à la
fois le plus complexe parce que c'est
vrai que ben voilà diversité en tout cas
des des
de cas qui peuvent être qui peut être
très différent
ce que j'ai ce que j'ai compris mais
c'est là où déjà j'avais peut-être une
première question c'est que dans les
annonces d'hier j'ai compris qu'en tout
cas la volonté du gouvernement était de
plutôt réorienter en tout cas sur de la
rénovation globale
alors maintenant vous avez plaît je
crois des travaux d'ampleur donc du coup
je voulais ma première question c'était
de savoir derrière ce terme qu'est-ce
que ça voulait dire est-ce que c'était
du BBC enfin qu'est-ce qu'il y avait
derrière sur terme vers quoi on ciblait
en tout cas sur cette rénovation
rénovation globale et donc c'est ces
travaux d'ampleur et c'est vrai qu'on
voit et dans les orientations et puis
les différents auditions qu'on a pu
avoir et puis différents enquêtes qui
ont été faits que c'est vraiment un
point sur lequel on peut dire qu'on a
été plus faible où on a très peu de
rénovation rénovation globale
vous en annoncez 20 000 enfin bon voilà
on peut discuter sur le sur les chiffres
mais on voit que c'est quand même très
faible et que une très grande partie en
tout cas de ma prime rénove et de du
financement est allé plus tôt sur des
gestes simples et sur ces gestes simples
en très grande majorité sur le
changement de chaudière
et c'est vrai que dans les annonces je
trouvais qu'il y avait un peu deux
éléments puisque j'entendais plutôt le
ministre Béchu annoncé plutôt de dire
qu'il fallait aller très rapidement sur
le changement de chaudière et sur la
décarbonation
peut-être quelque chose effectivement
d'intéressant mais du coup d'agir très
rapidement et très vite sur cette
question de la décore bonnation et du
changement de chaudière et donc du coup
de passer avec de la pompe à chaleur
donc déjà c'était voir comment on
pouvait articuler ces deux aspects c'est
à dire à la fois cette volonté de
vouloir aller très vite sur ce
changement de chaudière et sur des
carbonation mais en même temps motiver
l'ensemble des des propriétaires à aller
plutôt sur de la rénovation globale et
donc à quel moment en fait vous estimez
que cette orientation va se faire à quel
moment en fait on va orienter justement
ses propriétaires sur des choix qui font
que peut-être c'est peut-être enfin
voilà la chaudière va peut-être en bout
de course mais en tout cas dans leur
parcours de rénovation et donc en fait
ça me pose la question de savoir quand
est-ce que l'accompagne la compagnateur
rénove arrive en fait dans ce dans ce
dans ce schéma est-ce que à chaque fois
qu'il y aura une demande de subvention
et d'aide du coup il y aura forcément
l'accompagnateur Renov est-ce que c'est
quand il y a une volonté justement
d'aller sur de la rénovation globale que
là on devra passer vers la campagnateur
Renov mais donc du coup ça veut dire
si c'est si c'est ce deuxième ce
deuxième cas on sait aussi qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens liés aussi au
publicités au site internet etc qui vont
directement sur le changement de
chaudière sans se poser d'autres
questions donc comment justement on
arrive à mieux orienter par rapport à ce
que ce qui a pu être fait donc ça
c'était mes premières questions déjà sur
sur la question enfin sur la partie
plutôt plutôt individuelle et puis
une autre aussi dans les annonces qui
ont été faites hier il y avait de ça
c'est vrai quelque chose qu'on avait
bien vu et sur lequel on avait aussi
appuyé sur le fait de lier entre ma
prime rénov et les C2E et d'avoir
quelque chose de beaucoup plus lisible
et de plus mieux harmoniser en tout cas
sur les orientations
j'ai vu que c'était la volonté j'ai pas
vu vraiment de précision derrière et
même un aveu aussi je crois de la
ministre qui disait que c'était
compliqué en tout cas à mettre en place
mais est-ce que déjà vous avez des
pistes sur cet aspect là ensuite sur la
sur les copropriétés on sait que c'est
un des des à la fois là où on peut
massifier mais là où c'est aussi très
compliqué et il y avait la question du
DPE c'est vrai qu'on a vu que sur sur la
mise en place du DPE et du DPE opposable
sur les copropriétés et sur le collectif
ça pouvait poser un certain nombre de
problèmes avec des logements qui se
retrouvaient du coup
type passoire thermique ou en tout cas
qui qui risquait de ne plus être louable
mais intégrer dans une copropriété dans
lequel on a d'autres logements qui eux
sortent plutôt
que
reste reste louable et donc du coup
cette problématique en fait de
déclencher des travaux alors qu'on a des
des propriétaires qui ne sont pas sur le
même plan et donc savoir si la question
parce que je crois que ça a été aussi
évoqué du DPE collectif
pouvait être quelque chose de
d'envisageable en tout cas et d'avoir un
DPE collectif plutôt faisable sur les
copropriétés qui permettaient justement
d'avoir plutôt cette vision globale et
plus de solidarité en tout cas sur sur
l'avancée des travaux
et puis ensuite sur la partie
bailleur sociaux qui peut peut-être le
3e 3e bloc c'est vrai que quand on est
différente auditions qu'on a fait avec
les différents acteurs ce que je
trouvais plutôt rassurant c'est que tous
nous ont dit
on est enfin on est volontaire on sait
faire et c'est vrai que c'est le parc
d'ailleurs qui est le plus en avance
et on a envie de tenir en tout cas les
objectifs donc c'était plutôt quelque
chose je trouve très positif mais en
gros il nous faut les moyens et donc je
dirais que c'est peut-être la partie la
plus simple en fait et peut-être la plus
simple où on peut avancer très fortement
à condition qu'on mette les moyens
suffisants et qu'on puisse vraiment
apporter justement ces moyens au
bailleurs sociaux pour pouvoir avancer
très rapidement
et c'est vrai que là j'ai pas forcément
vu encore d'annonces très précise
justement sur sur ces moyens
supplémentaires en tout cas le moyen de
financement au niveau des bailleurs
sociaux et donc voilà ça peut être une
autre question ensuite pour terminer le
reste de questions il y avait le lien
peut-être parce qu'on a on a auditionné
à la fois ministre de l'écologie
et puis et puis vous-même et donc le
lien entre les différents ministères
ce que je disais un petit peu au début
des fois parfois les objectifs qui
peuvent être peut-être différents
suivant les ministères comment de votre
côté vous le vous le vivez en tout cas
ministère du Logement le lien avec
ministère d'écologie et avec les
orientations puisque c'est vrai qu'on
peut se dire que ministère du Logement
vous avez peut-être plutôt des exigences
justement sur de la rénovation globale
sur le confort lié à la santé et
et je dirais à l'aspect oui social et du
coup du du chauffage c'est vrai qu'on
peut avoir une orientation au ministère
de psychologie plutôt aller très vite
sur la décarbonation quitte à mettre de
côté justement la question de la
rénovation donc comment vous arrivez à
allier avec l'ensemble des des
ministères et est-ce que vous parait en
tout cas une bonne coordination et puis
savoir parce que ça c'est aussi quelque
chose mais je crois que madame la
Présidente l'aborder sur la question
d'une loi de programmation puisque c'est
vrai que dans les retours qu'on peut
avoir
c'est qu'il y a besoin à la fois de
lisibilité de lisibilité dans le temps
et donc d'avoir une vision à la fois
financière et un objectif sur du sur du
long terme et donc beaucoup de vos
prédécesseurs ont plutôt plaidé pour une
loi de programmation donc je voulais
aussi avoir votre votre avis sur ce sur
ce sujet voilà merci
voilà Monsieur le Ministre déjà un
certain nombre de questions que je suis
sûr vous allez nous apporter des
réponses intéressantes alors je vais je
vais essayer
sur le l'accompagne les deux piliers
efficacité et performance vous l'avez
dit
c'est ce que j'ai essayé de vous dire la
partie performance avec systématiquement
la présence d'un accompagnateur rénov
financé co-financé par les C2E c'est
vraiment un objectif pour que
chacun et toutes les informations
en sa possession pour connaître
notamment si j'ose dire le retour sur
investissement des travaux qui qui
qu'ils vont mener et avec un objectif
de 200 000 rénovations performantes donc
c'est un X3 par rapport à ce qui était
prévu jusqu'à présent une rénovation
globale et performante je crois l'avoir
dit mais je le redis parce que c'est
important c'est arrivé à une étiquette
AB en une ou deux étapes et ça c'est les
informations que donnera la compagnateur
qui a vraiment ce rôle de d'orientation
et et d'accompagnement et vous notre
objectif par rapport aux différents
modes de financement c'est deux heures
même prime rénove etc c'est bien que
d'une certaine manière ces questions-là
ne se posent pas à celui qui dépose son
son dossier ma prime rénov que ça soit
pour lui transparent le plus simple et
le plus lisible possible la manière dont
il va récupérer lui il a pas forcément
besoin de savoir si ces deux heures ou
un autre dispositif qui financent sur le
sur l'accompagnateur comme je l'ai dit
c'est d'essai deux heures ensuite pour
atteindre les 200 000 de rénovation
performantes il y a bien évidemment des
efforts financiers à faire dans le cadre
du plan du du de la loi de finances 2020
on établira les les sommes nécessaires
en précision parce que
sur ce qu'on a un peu pour l'instant
encore un peu du mal à avoir vraiment la
définition de la compagnateur de rénov à
quel moment il intervient alors le
processus donc c'est vrai que la porte
d'entrée c'est ma question du coup était
de
est-ce que du coup l'accompagnateur
reynose dire quelqu'un qui veut rénover
sa maison et qu'elle a volonté d'aller
justement dans nos rénovations d'ampleur
du coup va va faire appel à mon
accompagnement
systématiquement ou mais est-ce que
c'est systématiquement pour toucher des
aides quelle qu'elle soit ou c'est
vraiment parce qu'il y a la volonté
d'aller sur de la rénovation globale en
fait ma question c'est de voir c'est que
quelqu'un qui va aller va être dirigé
par exemple sur un site internet on va
lui dire bah en gros changer votre pompe
à chaleur et il suffit de remplir le
dossier etc comment ces personnes là on
les réoriente en fait justement pour
leur dire attention
si on est sur un seul geste le
changement d'un d'une pompe à chaleur et
donc de la fourniture d'énergie on peut
rester potentiellement dans le dans le
pilier efficacité donc c'est vraiment le
rôle de l'agence trans rénov du premier
contact et d'ailleurs on souhaite mieux
utiliser les maisons françaises comme
lieu d'entrée
là où c'est nécessaire pour avoir un
contact physique entre entre le
potentiel
particulier qui va lancer des travaux et
donc la première étape c'est passé par
une agence français-nov ou de manière
physique ou de manière dématérialisée en
fonction des échanges qu'il y aura avec
le conseiller France rénov il y aura une
première évaluation qui qui dira si on
est dans le pilier efficacité ou dans le
pilier performance
et parfois on pourra aussi passer d'un
pilier à l'autre en fonction du travail
c'est pour ça que
la règle actuelle c'est accompagnateur
pour la rénovation globale et
performante parce qu'il y a plusieurs
gestes et qu'il faut
avoir l'ensemble des informations pour
sortir de l'étiquette mais à un moment
rien n'empêche l'accompagnateur de dire
au final vous n'avez qu'un seul geste et
vous allez dans une dans un des piliers
mais c'est vrai et on le sait c'était le
risque qu'on a connu jusqu'à présent
parfois dans le monogest qui était utile
pour la planète en fonction de la baisse
des missions de gaz à effet de serre ça
n'avait pas forcément tous les avantages
qu'on aurait souhaité parce que changer
sa chaudière tout en gardant en étant la
terre d'une passoire donc c'est aussi le
vraiment le rôle du du premier contact
d'essayer d'évaluer il y a une toute une
série de questions qui qui doivent être
posées par par le conseiller France
Renov avant d'envoyer vers un
accompagnateur
sur les sur les autres questions
le DPE aujourd'hui la règle c'est un DP
individuel au logement parce que c'est
le niveau d'entrée sur la lutte contre
les passoires thermiques il y a pas
d'opposabilité du DPE collectif
néanmoins le DPE collectif peut rester
un outil à disposition d'une copropriété
pour connaître la situation de son
immeuble vous avez raison
ça reste une vraie question puisque on
le sait un certain nombre de
copropriétaires d'ailleurs ou occupants
peuvent dans un certain nombre de
Castres retrouver avec un logement d'une
certaine étiquette
toujours prendre l'exemple d'un bâtiment
explosé au Nord sous un toit terrasse
dans un chauffage à gaz est-ce qu'il
sera capable de sortir tout seul de son
étiquette si la copropriété n'a pas mis
en œuvre ou décider des travaux
nécessaire on peut se poser la question
dans quelques cas mais aujourd'hui la
règle reste celui du DPE individuel et
le DPE collectif seulement un outil
d'aide à la décision de la copropriété
mais ça reste un sujet qui est présent
dans notre esprit dans le travail que
l'on souhaite mener dans le
l'accompagnement des copropriétés et
leurs capacité à à décider des travaux
et à les financer
alors je reviens à votre question sur
les modes de chauffage et c'est pour ça
que je disais que la frontière est
parfois atténue entre efficacité et
performance il est hors de question pour
nous que un accompagne enfin que un
conseiller France rénove laisse engager
un particulier vers une transformation
un monogeste qui serait parfaitement
inutile donc c'est vraiment important
que que cette phase de de d'entretien et
d'échanges de premier échange permettent
de dire à une personne oui vous avez une
publicité vous pensez qu'il vous faut
passer sur une pompe à chaleur mais
vérifions ensemble quel est l'état de
votre logement avant de et puis si on
s'en on se rend compte qu'il y a un
décalage il faut orienter vers le bon
pilier et ça c'est vraiment le sens de
notre de notre démarche pour ce qui est
des bailleurs sociaux alors je partage
avec vous leur volontarisme mais c'est
extrêmement important pour nous c'est
un point d'appui extrêmement favorable
au démarche qui sont qui sont les nôtres
le travail que l'on mène avec Action
Logement la future signature de nous la
nouvelle convention quinquennale travail
que l'on mène avec l'USH et notre
volonté de signer avant avant le congrès
HLM en tout cas je le souhaite le pacte
de confiance nous oblige à travailler à
donner les moyens notamment aux
bailleurs les plus fragiles d'être dans
cette dynamique de réhabilitation il y a
le dispositif seconde vie qui va être
développé après son son expérimentation
donc ça donne accès à l'exode de TFPB
pour pour les bailleurs qui auront fait
des réhabilitations tellement lourdes
qu'on pourra considérer que l'immeuble
est neuf mais ce sera pas suffisant et
tout ne rentrera pas dans le dispositif
seconde vie donc il est important de
travailler avec les bailleurs avec
[Musique]
sur le lien entre les ministères
je crois qu'il y a une grande
complémentarité
entre nos objectifs d'abord parce que un
les questions climatiques se posent à
nous que la question de la rénovation
urbaine pour ma part dépasse la question
du logement vous connaissez mon
attachement à la question des
équipements publics et en particulier
des équipements scolaires et donc il est
extrêmement important aussi de
décarboner et de faire évoluer le
patrimoine bâti en particulier
patrimoine scolaire en confort d'hiver
confort d'été et donc c'est le sens de
du fond vert et et des aides que peuvent
apporter la des cils des TER ou d'autres
financements
et moi j'ai pas le sentiment qu'il y ait
au contraire de de
coin à mettre entre nos dynamiques elles
sont comme ça là était démontré hier
dans une grande complémentarité ensuite
une loi de programmation j'ai le
sentiment que on va oui comme l'a dit
mais mes collègues je pense qu'il faut
alors il y a déjà un certain nombre de
lois de programmation qui sont qui sont
en cours mais c'est pas la vie de
Christophe Béchu lui il a souhaité
favorable avec votre programmation non
mais on a déjà on a déjà des lois de
programmation qui qui court sur ces
questions là et c'est le je crois la
cohérence qui convient de continuer
de programmation pour 5 ans
reconductible 5 ans de plus
par rapport à l'existence je vois pas ce
que ça apporterait
on a déjà on a déjà des règles en cours
laisse la parole à nos collègues moi je
voudrais revenir vous avez parlé de la
mobilisation de tous l'écosystème avec
un comité des partenaires que vous avez
installé est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus
qui est ce comité des partenaires
comment voilà vous attendez qu'il
travaille avec vous et avec vos services
et un deuxième point
la fnaïm parle d'une vente en état futur
de rénovation énergétique c'est-à-dire
un contrat de vente qui soumettra la
transaction à la réalisation de travaux
de rénovation énergétique par les
vendeurs en intégrant le prix des
travaux dans le prix de la vente se
connaître votre avis sur cette
proposition
alors
j'entends les inquiétudes portées par
un certain nombre de partenaires sur un
la capacité de tenir le calendrier de la
loi climat et résilience les difficultés
techniques
de de mettre en oeuvre des
réhabilitations dans l'habitat collectif
et donc pour pouvoir partager ensemble
ces difficultés essayez de trouver des
des sorties on a mis en place ce comité
mi-avril je crois avec alors il y avait
la finale l'UNICE
le troisième m'échappe
l'UMP voilà
et puis un certain nombre d'acteurs du
bâtiment donc on est on regarde ensemble
les freins qui peuvent qui peuvent
exister moi je continue à penser que le
calendrier
est une cible verte vertueuse parce que
aujourd'hui on a des locataires qui
vivent dans des passoires thermiques et
on ne peut pas les laisser vivre dans de
telles conditions et mais j'entends
aussi les inquiétudes que portent les
acteurs du logement et ils connaissent
cet écosystème donc c'est important
qu'on travaille ensemble qu'on essaie de
comprendre les freins et et qu'on essaye
de de l'élever l'autre espion pardon
des travaux dans ensuite ça serait donc
dans le prix dans le prix des travaux
lorsque le dans le prix de vente travaux
seraient intégré dans le prix de vente
ce que vous pensez que c'est de nature
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
d'interdiction de vente une passoire une
passoire thermique par exemple l'annonce
de la première ministre lors du CNR de
dire qu'on pourrait bénéficier du PTZ
dans l'ancien sous réserve en zone
détendue sous réserve de travaux et
énergétiques rentrent dans cet esprit la
capacité que l'on donne que l'on donne
de créer du logement intermédiaire dans
des dans des dispositifs d'acquisition
amélioration peuvent aussi rentrer dans
ces dispositifs ce qui est certain c'est
que
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui achèterait une
passoire thermique pour y habiter sera
immédiatement éligible aux différents
aux différentes aides
vente qui soumettrai la transaction à la
réalisation de travaux de rénovation
énergétique et ensuite en intégrerait
les travaux dans le prix de vente
ce qu'ils appellent eux une vente en
l'état futur de rénovation énergétique
c'est une décote mais elle est déjà
d'une certaine manière ça ça reste du
tout si vous voulez ça reste d'une
discussion de grec agréé de toute façon
avec avec le DPE on achète en toute
connaissance de cause je vois pas bien
ce que ça changerait en fait je peux
alors y a-t-il des questions du côté de
nos collègues
Sabine dragster oui merci beaucoup
monsieur le ministre alors je voulais
vous demander si vous pensez que le DPE
est actuellement suffisamment adapté au
bâti patrimonial je pense au bâti qui
n'est pas protégé est-ce que pour vous
il prend suffisamment en compte les
particules les particularités du bâti
vernaculaire ou est-ce qu'il faudrait
pouvoir l'adapter pour mieux tenir
compte des qualités notamment d'inertie
et de confort d'été aussi de ce type de
bâti et pour éviter également des gestes
techniques ou la pose de matériaux qui
pourrait lui porter préjudice
alors c'est une question extrêmement
importante avec lequel sur lequel on
travaille avec
les services du ministère de la Culture
les architectes des bâtiments de France
sur la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments patrimoniaux on soutient une
expérimentation sur ce label des
performances
énergétiques
il faut
aujourd'hui les études montrent qu'on
peut rénover aussi les bâtiments de
patrimo patrimoniaux bien évidemment en
utilisant on va pas faire une ite sur un
bâtiment à colombage ou sur ou sur de la
pierre de taille agrafer de la même
manière que on pourrait le faire sur un
bâtiment des années des années 60 donc
il faut continuer à travailler sur les
évolutions techniques aujourd'hui il y a
pas de prévu d'une évolution du DPE sur
sa méthodologie dans l'ancien mais il
faut
parce que l'évolution du DPE a est
adaptée déjà au bâti anciens néanmoins
on essaye de travailler à l'amélioration
de de ces de ces critères
pour que ma prime rénove copropriété
notamment puisse prendre en compte les
spécificités techniques les surcos
éventuels des rénovations une rénovation
par l'intérieur c'est pas la même chose
que par l'extérieur et ensuite on a un
certain nombre de dispositifs fiscaux le
dénormandie par exemple qui normalement
mais qui est aujourd'hui très peu
utilisé
permettrait de d'alimenter le
les travaux de rénovation dans l'ancien
pour des critères écologiques et
énergétiques
c'est vraiment un travail qui est en
cours mais pour l'instant à notre
analyse le DPE tel qu'il existe
aujourd'hui est adapté à l'ancien
sur le terrain on constate quand même
qu'actuellement des gens des gens
isolent des du bâti patrimonial de
manière inadaptée donc je pense qu'il y
a aussi un gros effort de communication
à faire ça
qu'il y ait des
chantiers inadaptés avec autorisation
dans le cadre d'une parce que tout
chantier de ce type doit est soumis à
des autorisations
d'urbanisme classique que ce soit une
autorisation de travaux ou un permis etc
donc un moment
c'est le rôle ou de le PC ou de la
municipalité de ne pas laisser faire des
travaux qui ne sont pas respectueux
jusqu'à certains que ces travaux là ont
été fait avec un accompagnateur rénov et
dans les règles de l'art
oui quelques petites questions la
première sur les copro
une des hypothèses enfin en tout cas que
la Fédération des cops HLM Vous avez
suggéré puisque vous savez que cette
fédération comme certains bailleurs HLM
peuvent jouer un rôle de syndic dans les
copropriétés c'était l'idée d'un contrat
global de réhabilitation qui s'apparente
un peu importe financier
comparable aux OSS c'est à dire en clair
la copropriété
pourrait prendre en charge l'ensemble
des travaux de réhabilitation thermique
et ferait payer à chacun des
propriétaires une part étalée sur la
longue durée transmissible lors de la
transmission du bien est-ce que cette
hypothèse est travaillée quelque part
dans les services de vos services ou
dans celui de Madame panier une assez en
tout cas ça nous paraissait être un des
leviers permettant de débloquer le vote
la majoritaire dans les assemblées
générales qui demeurent quand même un
objectif important car même si on
assouplit les règles de vote faut quand
même que les gens puissent payer donc ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième point
concerne le parc HLM donc en effet le
monde HLM je crois est très mobilisé
pour atteindre des objectifs mais on se
doit un discours de vérité sur ce qui
est réellement nécessaire or on est
devant une de conjonction ou quand le
mouvement Hlm fait ces simulations
d'investissement il a il calcule à peu
près à 9 milliards l'investissement
annuel nécessaire pour les
réhabilitations
dedans pour y considérer que la longue
durée c'est de l'ordre de 1 milliard un
milliard 1 donc il y a encore 8
milliards à trouver donc avec des degrés
de réhabilitation ils ont un peu 5 50
entre très lourd et un peu moins lourd
et quand on fait le calcul de des coûts
moyens avant la hausse du livret A on
arrive à 9 milliards et là on arrive à
goulot d'étranglement double qui est
premièrement c'est en tout cas je crois
que l'USA je vous a transmet ces
chiffres on est devant un double double
boulet d'étranglement on est à Goulette
des tremblements fonds propres des
organismes et un goulet d'étrangle et
qui vont évidemment d'après toutes les
simulations être particulièrement
affaiblie notamment avec la hausse des
taux du livret A donc on ne pourra rien
obtenir de majeur aide signifiant s'il y
a pas une consolidation des fonds
propres désorganismes et deuxièmement
d'autant plus qu'on ne céléréable
demande plus de fonds propres que les
constructions et deuxièmement le niveau
des aides puisque vous parlez d'un fond
si on compare les objectifs à atteindre
les évolutions
et les besoins actuellement on est sur
200 millions d'euros le niveau d'aide
calculer toutes choses par ailleurs
comparé à ça c'est 1,2 milliards donc il
faut bien prendre la mesure des choses
et je ne crois pas que c'est par une
stratégie pure sup d'allongement des
prêts qu'on va pouvoir résoudre ce
problème donc là on retombe dans des
débats macro économique liée au monde
HLM qui est notamment la RLS les aides à
la pierre stedra alors je sais bien que
la discussion va avoir lieu mais nous
sommes sénateurs et sénatrice et on
aimerait savoir si quand la Première
ministre parle d'une augmentation des
fonds quel est l'ordre de grandeur si
c'est pour passer à 300 000 ou 400 000
ça va être des clopinettes par rapport
aux objectifs
donc cette question sur le monde HLM
même si je note avec intérêt
l'engagement pris sur les
configurations globale deuxième vie
troisième volet
c'est un problème de j'allais dire de
communication et de vérité sur on
annonce tout le temps plein de milliards
on sait pas combien on a économiser gaz
à effet de serre voire même de
consommation énergétique des bâtiments
concernés c'est à dire
pourquoi je dis ça c'est les Allemands
nous ont fait tout un pipeau sur on a
beaucoup réhabilité à Berlin un machin
puis quand ils font leur bilan
c'est pas si mirobolant que ça
et d'ailleurs même s'interroge sur le
rapport entre le niveau d'investissement
qu'ils ont mis et les résultats obtenus
alors je ne plaise pas pour dire on
n'arrivera pas donc on arrête je pense
quand même qu'il y a une pédagogie à
expliquer ben voilà dans un état on a
mis tant d'argent on a à peu près gagné
de temps voilà les blocages qu'on
rencontre parce que je crois que nous
concitoyens à force d'entendre des
milliards n'y croient plus et pourtant
souvent on les dépense enfin un million
milliards souvent on les dépenses et
deux ils ont l'impression parfois que
c'est le tonneau des Danaïdes une fois
qu'on a mis l'argent finalement ça règle
pas grand chose donc je me demande si
dans vos dans les visions que vous avez
de l'accompagnement politique de ce que
la nation fait comme effort il serait
pas judicieux d'avoir comme ça une
espèce d'observatoire pilote partager
qu'il soit pas tout le monde braille de
son côté en soit c'est pas les bons
chiffres pour essayer de faire
progresser en commun
le pays parce que par ailleurs il vous a
pas échappé que on entend tous les
quarts d'heure c'est honteux la France
fait rien bon je passe soutenir le
gouvernement je pense qu'il fait passer
mais néanmoins et la France n'est pas le
pire pays à faire rien du tout quoi au
bout d'un moment ça démoralisé français
on a toujours été l'impression d'être
les nuls de chez nul donc voilà ma ma
troisième question
merci
sur sur les copros moi je évidemment si
on veut massifier la rénovation
thermique et énergétique du logement
c'est à travers l'habitat collectif et
en particulier l'habitat privé
on connaît on connaît les freins le
premier frein c'est le reste à charge et
donc à travers
le pilier performance la transformation
de la prime rénov copropriété c'est
essayer de diminuer au maximum le reste
à charge en particulier pour les plus
fragiles le deuxième frein c'est celui
de la vie de la copropriété et ça fait
partie des sujets qui sont les nôtres
aujourd'hui vous le savez une
copropriété lorsqu'elle doit voter des
travaux c'est une assemblée générale des
corums des votes majorité simple
majorité qualifiée en fonction de la
nature de de ces chantiers et donc notre
objectif c'est de simplifier la
démocratie de la copro et
et la loi de de 65
sur le reste à charge il y a à
développer à la fois les aides mais
aussi le soutien bancaire à travers le
prêt les coprais à taux zéro le prix
financement
vous savez pour dans une copropriété une
fois qu'on a voté les travaux et qu'on a
créé le compte travaux il faut
l'alimenter à travers les appels de
fonds aujourd'hui
ce système est évidemment celui qui
prévaut mais c'est toujours pareil on
sait comment ça marche et si on voit pas
de début de chantier ça n'alimente pas
l'envie des gens de payer et on sait que
on veut travailler avec le monde
bancaire à un prêt financement de ces
chantiers pour pouvoir
avoir et c'est vrai pour des opérations
d'intérêt national de toute façon les
grands chantiers que l'on doit mener
dans les copropriétés de rénovation de
sécurisation prennent en compte aussi
les chantiers de de réhabilitation il y
a pas un plan de sauvegarde aujourd'hui
ou une opération d'intérêt national hors
code qui ne prend pas en compte les
questions des réalisations énergétiques
du bâti et là par rapport à la question
que vous posiez madame la sénatrice sur
avoir un
une avance en tout cas une espèce de un
prêt voilà
on réfléchit dans ce cas d'un appel à
projet France 2030 à un tiers
investisseur qui pourrait porter pendant
un temps le chantier et permettre
ce système avec un remboursement sur les
économies d'énergie donc ça fait partie
des des pistes que des modèles que l'on
veut tester pour que la trésorerie
initiale de la copro ne soit pas un
frein au lancement de ces chantiers mais
mais ça demande à être à aide
expérimenté alors il y a la version
réduite qui n'a pas encore forcément
marché je crois que c'est madame la
Présidente qui l'a évoqué le prêt avance
rénovation tout à l'heure qui est quand
même un système qui pourrait être
vertueux c'est vrai qu'en France on n'a
pas forcément envie de faire porter sur
nos descendants ou au moment de la vente
des prêts qu'on aura contractés mais ça
reste un dispositif qui je crois mérite
d'être mieux présenté par par les
banquiers que que quel prêt avance
rénovation parce qu'on est à 34 de
mémoire pour pour l'année c'est ridicule
au regard de l'intérêt
des banques aussi voilà je pense que on
a un vrai besoin que les banques
informent mieux sur sur ce dispositif
bien sûr
ronome un des problèmes qu'on rencontre
chez les copropriétaires c'est pas
seulement la vente c'est la capacité à
payer or en payant en longue durée et en
permettant comme on le fait pour le BRS
de transmettre la charge alors
évidemment on va pas faire 45 ans comme
le BRS il faut que ce soit des
permettent de transférer si je puis dire
la la contribution remboursement on a un
mécanisme beaucoup plus fluide avec une
responsabilité de la copro elle-même moi
je crois que c'est plus simple que alors
quitte à ce qu'elle a copro est un
accord avec une banque pour faire ça ou
la CDC si elle a des dans certains cas
mais en tout cas
honnêtement la succession des aides
bancaires aux individus ne règlera pas
le problème ça n'a toujours à la dedans
qui est interdit bancaire qu'un machin
Bosa qui est ils sont trois et de
propriétaires enfin bon on est devant
des mécanismes complexes bon je veux pas
installer maintenant mais il y a une
expérimentation à Rennes que je peux
vous faire connaître qui a été à
plusieurs qui étaient faits avec la
communauté
urbaine de Rennes et
des organismes ça fait partie des sujets
qu'on compte sur lesquels on travaille
avec Lana le la question de l'aide à la
copropriété ou au copropriétaires font
partie des sujets qui doivent être
évalués pour pour avoir le plus
d'efficacité possible après les
situations d'une copro à 5 n'est pas la
même que une situation d'une copro à à
200 et une copro de gens qui ont un peu
d'argent on n'est pas la même qu'une
copro fragile donc c'est pour ça qu'il
faut qu'on évalue et c'est aussi le sens
des réflexion que l'on mène sur une
éventuelle loi sur la copropriété
l'habitat insalubre et la lutte contre
les marchands de sommeil que qui me
semblent nécessaires de porter pour
aller plus vite sur sur ces projets
lever les les différents freins qui
peuvent encore exister à la à la
réhabilitation copro et en particulier
la rénovation énergétique sur le parc
social je vais pas aller beaucoup plus
loin que ce que j'ai dit tout à l'heure
il y a vraiment une volonté bien
évidemment d'accompagner les bailleurs à
travers tous les dispositifs possibles y
compris celui des prêts l'allongement
etc mais aussi pour les plus fragiles de
regarder avec eux comment on peut leur
redonner un certain nombre de capacités
d'investissement tant pour la production
neuve que pour pour la réhabilitation
la hausse de la livret a déjà été
contenue en février par un par une fort
volontarisme et du gouverneur de la
Banque de France et du ministère de
l'économie et des finances même si ça a
été porté à 3%, il y a eu quand même une
on était en dessous de ce qu'il y aurait
pu être fait sur le nouveau taux du
livret A il va y avoir une réévaluation
du taux en août sur lequel il faudra
qu'on soit attentif et là encore si elle
devait augmenter ce qui est aussi l'INT
des petits épargnants faut trouver
l'équilibre
entre les deux il y aurait nécessité de
continuer à accompagner le monde HLM à
travers des des remboursements
plus tardif ou des allongements des
allongements des prêts pour ce qui est
du de la transparence et
des économies réelles faites grâce aux
différents chantiers
vous avez vous avez raison il est
important qu'on qu'on est en train de
faire tous les calculs la diminution des
gaz à effet de serre et ça il y a des
outils qui permettent de d'évaluer notre
objectif et la tenue de nos objectifs de
diminuer en 2030 puis 2000 puis 2050 il
y a des chiffres que je cite souvent sur
les 1,5 millions de de chantier ma prime
rénov qui ont permis
d'économiser à peu près la consommation
électrique annuelle de la ville de Lyon
en gros une ville de 600 000 habitants
mais ça demande à être plus scientifique
et moi je partage parce que parce que
cette capacité à
à la transparence de la réalité des
économies d'énergie de la diminution des
gaz à effet de serre c'est une bonne
pédagogie une bonne pédagogie pour
continuer à financer ces politiques une
bonne pédagogie pour pour nos
concitoyens de se lancer dans ces
chantiers et évidemment
pour qu'ils aient aussi la connaissance
de l'effet sur leur portefeuille y
compris sur sur la planète donc il y a
plusieurs dispositifs et on est en train
de d'y travailler sur pour encore plus
éclairé à la fois les parlementaires
mais nos concitoyens
oui je vais revenir sur la question du
logement social alors comme Marie-Noëlle
l'a fait pas sur toutes les questions
financières peut-être plus sur la
question on va dire de l'enseignement
technique que pourrait représenter
l'expérimentation seconde vie ou
l'équivalent on va dire chez les grands
gestionnaires nationaux de copro c'est à
dire les premiers grands chantiers qui
vont pouvoir se dérouler pour massifier
comment est-ce qu'on peut faire le lien
pour arriver en tirer un enseignement
après technique sur les filières sur les
appels d'offres sur la manière de
procéder sur des financements etc qui
servent le logement social a toujours
servi de laboratoire souvent au logement
dit plus classique donc je pense que
c'est je pense que c'est extrêmement
important de savoir comment on peut
faire le lien entre ces alors il y a des
avancées puisque
il y a une périnisation qui a été
annoncée mais c'est presque trop court
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné il
faut une visibilité aussi sur
plus que 2024 ou l'année d'après mais
pour pouvoirifier parce qu'on sait que
l'enjeu est là après je vais revenir sur
sur ma maraud du confort d'été
[Rires]
de voilà de de dès que on peut
effectivement communiquer sur sur ce
sujet là comme on sait que il y a plus
de Français qui souffrent de la chaleur
que du froid et qu'on a vu que ces
éléments là sont pas intégrés
suffisamment à mon sens dans la même dès
le départ du diagnostic etc et que pour
un certain nombre de sujets parfois les
solutions techniques sont peuvent être
assez simples mais je pense qu'il faut
il faut vraiment changer de paradigme
sur sur cette partie là et qu'on arrête
de voir uniquement sur le volet sur le
volet hiver
et froid et s'appuyer aussi
sur on n'a pas beaucoup évoqué
aujourd'hui mais sur toute la structure
dans les collectivités sur les
territoires
de structures qui existent à initiative
parfois départementale PNL Alec etc pour
vraiment ne pas réinventer à chaque fois
l'eau chaude et pouvoir s'appuyer ce qui
est le cas parce que je vois sur la
lettre Essonne à l'heure actuelle j'ai
fait mon test mon bêta test pour essayer
d'aller voilà et on est directement
relié sur ma prime rénove et sur un le
conseiller etc donc le lien est le lien
est fait mais voilà qu'on ne le perde
pas
alors je partage complètement le la
notion de laboratoire du logement social
et la manière dont le la seconde vie
pourrait être
utile
aux copropriété en particulier
probablement les les grandes
copropriétés mais mais pas seulement sur
sur la manière dont on peut
accompagner chiffrer les rénovations et
énergétiques alors il y a eu le nom
m'échappe
dans le cadre du plan de relance un
accompagnement des des copropriétés sur
une méthodologie
simplifiée de la de la rénovation
énergétique
Massy Reno merci
oui c'est pour le logement social déjà
ma cyreno pardon on a été en visiter une
je sais plus où c'était mais enfin bon
donc oui il y a eu il y a eu pour pour
le logement social pardon une expérience
dans le cas du plan de Renan c'est et
qui est aussi
utile à à
d'autres rénovations
énergétiques du parc à la fois dans le
privé et dans le dans le dans le
logement social les rénovations seconde
vie le seront aussi il faudra qu'on
regarde il est encore trop tôt je crois
pour en tirer les les enseignements mais
vous avez raison il faudra qu'on mette
ce chantier et ses chantiers à profit la
question du du confort d'été vous avez
raison elle est extrêmement importante
elle est pas aujourd'hui directement
dans les étiquettes de la DPE puisque il
se concentre entre guillemets de
regarder les critères de consommation en
énergie primaire et les émissions de gaz
à effet de serre rajouter à ce stade un
nouveau critères dans l'étiquette je
suis pas certain que que ce soit
utile peut-être même un peu du contraire
à la lisibilité néanmoins il y a des
indicateurs hors étiquettes sur le
DPE sur les outils de passifs de baisse
de la de la température les brise-vues
les protections solaires etc et puis
dans le cadre de la R20 aussi il y a un
certain nombre de techniques de
construction qui peuvent être prises en
compte et puis aujourd'hui nos
aménageurs et les EPA peuvent aussi dans
le cadre des programmes qu'ils mènent
sur les territoires avoir des
indications spécifiques au confort d'été
une agence que je connais bien la rue
qui a lancé quartier des résiliants il y
a quelques une petite année bientôt est
attentif à ces questions là des îlots de
chaleur notamment
dans les équipements publics les
équipements les équipements scolaires
donc évidemment le confort d'été quand
on entend le le bruit qui qui est au
dessus de nous depuis le début de cette
réunion et est une question extrêmement
importante ou quand l'ancien maire que
je suis est en train de faire une
information auprès de ses habitants sur
que faire en cas de fortes chaleurs
préparer nos salles fraîches pour
accueillir nos seniors je n'ai aucun
doute sur cette question elle est
extrêmement prégnante et elle risque de
de nous occuper et on le voit je parlais
des écoles tout à l'heure on voit à quel
point les pics de chaleur qu'on est en
train de connaître en ce moment
nuit à la qualité de l'enseignement dans
beaucoup de nos écoles juste
une je peux rajouter une petite remarque
pour moi c'est pas rajouter une ligne
puisqu'en fait quand on utilise de la
clim on peut calculer aussi
j'allais dire le coût énergétique des
pensées si une fine et la solution c'est
de mettre une clim qu'elle soit
réversible ou pas électrique et on n'a
pas forcément tout solutionné donc voilà
vous avez complètement raison et
vous connaissez ce sujet parfaitement et
je partage votre votre analyse ils ça
fait partie des sujets y compris dans le
choix des couleurs des peintures dans le
choix des matériaux sur lequel il faut
qu'on travaille dans le cadre de la
ville durable ça fait partie des
chantiers qui qui sont les nôtres et sur
lesquels les architectes les urbanistes
les aménageurs doivent chacun prendre
leur part bien évidemment
alors peut-être après encore monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez réuni à quelques
semaines de cela les diagnostiqueurs
immobiliers je crois et vous avez donc
annoncé qu'il y aurait un certain nombre
de mesures d'ici l'été bien sûr pour
mieux professionnaliser ce métier
combien important parce qu'on voit aussi
que aujourd'hui voilà il y a
diagnostiqueur et diagnostiqueur et que
certains peuvent s'improviser
diagnostiqueurs sans avoir eu aucune
formation qu'elle soit initiale ou
continue est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire un petit peu plus qu'elles peuvent
être les mesures auxquelles vous avez
réfléchi et qui pourrait être mise en
oeuvre et ensuite une question sur
les contrôles aujourd'hui comment
d'après vous peut-on assurer un de
meilleurs contrôles des travaux de
rénovation énergétique justement pour
mieux lutter contre la fraude est-ce que
pour vous par exemple il serait
envisageable de mieux coordonner
partager les résultats d'un côté avec ma
prime rénove et ses deux œufs et de
l'autre côté le label RGE
dans un souci aussi de simplification
mais peut-être de plus grande efficacité
quand on contrôle qui pourrait être
réalisé et très souvent monsieur le
rapporteur l'a rappelé au cours des
auditions en tout cas à poser cette
question sur la mise en place d'un
contrôle type consuel qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
alors sur effectivement les
diagnostiqueurs ont été réunis dans une
un webinaire comme on dit comme on dit
maintenant pour éviter que leur
déplacement en a même lieu et est un
bilan carbone désastreux
moi je leur ai rappelé leur obligation
d'exemplarités je pense que il y a
vraiment
vous l'avez dit dans votre propos
introductrice madame la Présidente c'est
insupportable d'avoir sur un même
logement des diagnostics contradictoires
des diagnostics qui démontreraient poste
travaux qu'on n'a pas monté en étiquette
mais qu'on a baissé donc ils ont une
obligation un diagnostic ça se fait pas
pour une somme dérisoire en quelques
minutes ça prend du temps et donc il est
extrêmement important et c'est pour ça
que au-delà de ce webinaire on travaille
sur la formation initiale pour obtenir
la certification
et on travaille avec l'ensemble de cette
de cette filière si si j'ose dire on
renforce la formation initiale en
participe à la possibilité d'avoir des
formations de de courte durée à travers
des outils là aussi numériques des MOOC
comme on dit maintenant
il faut homogénéiser la manière
aujourd'hui il y a une fiche qui permet
évidemment
au diagnostiqueur de répondre et de
répondre de manière homogène à aux
questions il y a une fiche à destination
du propriétaire pour qu'il sache ce
qu'est un DPE et quels sont les
questions qui qui sont posées pour que
le cas échéant si on arrive à un
résultat qui paraît improbable
incompréhensible le propriétaire puisse
se retourner et
indiquer le risque auprès de l'Agence
France Renov par exemple pour que dire
voilà j'ai fait appel à solida you
stickers je suis très étonné
je suis diagnostic de mon logement il
est contradictoires avec le diagnostic
qu'a fait mon voisin enfin que sais-je
et je pense qu'il est extrêmement
important et donc il faut et ça a été
dit à la filière de diagnostic renforcer
aussi les contrôles vous avez raison
et les surveillances postes
postier et donc ça fait partie des des
sujets qui sont qui sont à l'oeuvre pour
ce qui est de la fraude en général
c'est c'est enfin je l'ai dit dans mon
propos liminaire si si on veut que ces
dispositifs soient soit crédible et
utiles il faut faire de la fraude un
ennemi on a des fraudes on a eu des
fraudes quasiment mafieuses sur un
certain nombre de programmes c'est pour
ça aussi par moment on a eu des
difficultés avec avec des réponses de
Lana compris plus de temps parce que il
a fallu s'organiser contre contre on a
aussi par moments et c'est pour ça que
l'accompagnateur rénov est extrêmement
important des mandataires qui qui sont
alors pour certains de qualité et c'est
très bien et ça permet aux particuliers
qui a une somme de chantier de faire
appel à un mandataire qui va
diriger les travaux
choisir avec lui les différents les
différents artisans qui réaliseront les
travaux mais on a aussi des mandataires
qui ont fait appel à à des entreprises
de piètre de piètre qualité et donc ça
obligé Lana à après contrôle à vérifier
que la réalité des travaux ont bien été
ont bien été réalisés donc on a vraiment
un objectif extrêmement ferme de de
lutte contre les fraudes on a un travail
que l'on mène avec la CAPEB avec la FFB
sur les
les entreprises et la qualification RGE
parce que évidemment on a besoin
d'entreprises avec la qualification pour
pour avoir ce niveau de qualité moi je
je suis et je l'ai déjà dit favorable à
l'expérimentation qui a été lancée à la
demande de la CAPEB et suite aux assises
du bâtiment de la labilisation par
chantier vous savez une entreprise qui
aura été qui aura fait un certain nombre
de chantier réussi de rénovation
énergétique de mémoire C3 après contrôle
pourrait obtenir sa qualification RGE je
pense que c'est une bonne méthode cette
qualification au chantier sous réserve
que on soit en capacité de contrôler la
qualité des travaux qui ont été faits en
tout cas c'était expérimentation a été
prolongée dans le cadre des Assises du
bâtiment et en principe on doit le
refaire une réunion des assises avec
Bruno Le Maire fin juin début juillet
pour voir si cette méthodologie serait
conservée par par la suite
merci non je voulais quelques peut-être
quelques précisions sur le DPE parce
qu'il y a des c'est vrai qu'on voit puis
vous l'avez vous l'avez dit ça devient
un dispositif très central en tout cas
dans le dans les politiques qu'on met en
place puisqu'on se base sur ce sur ce
DPE et sur du coup l'évolution de ce DPE
on voit qu'il y a des évolutions je
pense que l'ensemble des acteurs qu'on a
pu auditionner
même s'il y a des remarques etc sur le
despe je pense que le message était
plutôt de dire un arrêtons de changer et
donc plutôt confortons quelque chose
mais par contre essayons de de
l'améliorer de réorienter c'est vrai que
la question du du confort thermique
d'été qui n'est pas pris en compte je
pense que c'est une quand même une
problématique et ça va avec aussi le le
bâti ancien ou traditionnel et en tout
cas tout ce qui peut être matériau
biosourcés qui sont absolument pas
intégrés en tous ceux qui sont
dévalorisés dans le DPE et qui posent
une vraie question parce que du coup
c'est des matériaux qu'on pourrait
utiliser justement sur l'ancien qui ont
un intérêt sur le confort thermique
d'été et pourtant qui du coup sont oui
sont clairement des favorisés dans les
dans les DPE donc je pense qu'il y a un
est-ce que du coup il y a quand même une
réflexion pour faire évoluer ce DPE et
peut-être le rendre encore plus précis
et performant et ensuite j'avais une
question parce que c'est vrai que sur la
question de la fraude ce qu'on peut voir
en fait dans la dans la question de la
fraude c'est
comment la fraude arrive en fait
bénéficie toujours sur des gens qui
n'ont pas l'information qui ne
connaissent pas trop ce qu'ils ont à
faire et du coup qui sont abusés quoi et
sur la question de la rénovation
thermique c'est exactement ça pendant on
a des gens d'ailleurs qui avaient même
pas pensé
agir sur thermique ou sur un changement
de chaudière et c'est via en fait des
entreprises peut-être parfois peu
scrupuleuses en tout cas qui viennent
les démarcher et qui vont leur proposer
tel ou tel ou telle dispositif et dont
je me dis qu'en fait cette c'est pour ça
que je revenais sur la campagnateur
Renov à quel moment il intervient je
pense que plutôt en fait on permettra
aux
propriétaires d'avoir l'information de
savoir un comment est leur logement
est-ce que je suis dans une passoire
thermique est-ce que je suis A B C D E
et la plupart du temps on ne le sait pas
et du coup qu'est-ce qu'il faudrait que
je fasse pour progresser et donc ma
question elle était plutôt de savoir si
le DPE que je trouve un outil plutôt
intéressant qui en plus donne des
orientations de travaux et de
priorisation des travaux quand on fait
un DPE est-ce que la question de la
généralisation de ce DPE pourrait être
quelque chose en tout cas de d'envisager
je pense notamment enfin si on fait le
parallèle avec le contrôle technique des
voitures
tout le monde a son contrôle technique
c'est où et sa voiture et puis avec une
période d'icité voilà et c'est vrai que
là actuellement il y a pas d'obligation
d'avoir sauf à la vente sauf à la
location mais il y a pas d'obligation
d'avoir de DPE donc même si on fait des
travaux même si on change sa chaudière
n'a pas d'obligation d'avoir de DPE et
donc du coup ça revient aussi à ce que
disait Marie-Noël Liman sur sur la
visibilité sur le de ce qu'on peut
mettre parce que je pense que le fait
d'avoir un DPE généralisé ça permettrait
d'avoir une visibilité complète sur
l'ensemble des logements et ça
permettrait de voir l'évolution à chaque
fois de savoir et donc soit de le rendre
obligatoire en fonction des aides soit
peut-être de le généraliser avec des
échéances mais il me semble que ça
pourrait être en tout cas un élément qui
permet d'avoir une visibilité sur les
sur les politiques qui peuvent être mis
en place et sur l'évolution de ces
politiques et puis surtout qui
permettrait quand même d'avoir un
minimum d'informations auprès des
propriétaires de se dire voilà je suis
je suis pas sur Terminer je suis en G je
sais les orientes des grandes
orientations je sais qu'il faut
peut-être plutôt que je fasse
l'isolation par l'extérieur et le Mékong
et mes fenêtres et ensuite la chaudière
mais j'ai au moins ces informations là
qui m'évitent justement de tomber
ensuite dans tout ce mécanisme de de
fraude ou en tout cas d'abus qui peut
qui peut y avoir
donc voilà du coup voir un petit peu
cette aspect là si c'est quelque chose
qui avait été en tout cas envisagé ou
évoqué
alors je redis un mot sur la fraude en
général parce que vraiment c'est c'est
pour nous une grande préoccupation et
dans les campagnes de pub on le redit il
y a pas de démarchage par par ni par
l'ADN ni par Lana etc et c'est important
qu'on le redise à nos concitoyens le
seul accompagnement et c'est celui qui
vaut c'est celui des accompagnateurs des
conseillers France Renov et des
accompagnateurs rénovs et je pense que
c'est important qu'on le partage on va
lancer une campagne de publicité à la
rentrée sur sur ma prime rénov et c'est
de piliers qui redira la seule porte
d'entrée c'est celle là et il n'écoutez
pas les publicités etc et on y est très
très attentif parce que sinon on va
perdre en crédibilité ensuite sur le DP
il a évolué en juillet 21 2021 de
mémoire je pense qu'il est
utile de
pu le faire évoluer à ce stade parce que
le faire à nouveau évoluer
poserait des questions sur les DPE et
les étiquettes existantes je pense que
maintenant il faut de la stabilité les
critères qui ont été revus et consolidés
sont fiables ils sont le plus objectif
possible
le chauffage
au moment de l'étiquette l'isolation et
un certain nombre de de sujets qui ont
qui ont été mis en place au moment de sa
réforme en 2021
je l'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut qu'on
soit extrêmement vigilant auprès des
diagnostiqueurs sur l'homogénéité de
leur travail et il faut qu'il soit
vraiment très très clair sur cette sur
ce travail et on les a rappelé à l'herbe
à l'aide à l'ordre pardon lors de ce
webinaire je crois qu'ils ont entendu et
que c'est leur souhait d'avoir une
moralisation de de leur de leur travail
pour que ils aient le plus de
crédibilité possible ensuite
je partage assez ce que ce que vous
dites sur
cette cet outil extrêmement vertueux
quelle étiquette quel que soit enfin en
tout cas dans celle qui qui existe
aujourd'hui
quand on s'arrête devant une agence
immobilière
une des premières choses qu'on regarde
avant de regarder les photos c'est le
coin en bas avec avec les étiquettes
pour voir la qualité du logement qu'on
souhaite louer ou acheter nous on est
encore en face de réflexion par rapport
aux deux piliers dont je vous ai parlé
tout à l'heure pilier efficacité
j'ai le sentiment que si on veut être
complètement équilibré dans nos dans nos
choix on a besoin au moins
d'avoir une étiquette pour savoir d'où
on part et où on va aujourd'hui il y a
pas d'obligation mais vous avez raison
c'est c'est une vraie question qui se
pose pour ce qui a du critère
performance là dans la mesure où il y a
un diagnostic un accompagnement il y
aura connaissance d'une étiquette du
logement avant avant et après sur la
partie efficacité c'est pas rendu
obligatoire en tant que tel à ce stade
de la réflexion mais je j'y suis pas a
priori hostile bien évidemment
il y a la question du coup qui qui se
pose et de qui porte
ce coup même si il peut paraître peu
important au regard du chantier il
existe mais mais j'entends et vous avez
peut-être raison avoir un diagnostic
obligatoire systémique pour tout le
monde
[Musique]
je vais pas de réponse à ce stade moi
j'ai vu
eladème et le CSTB ont des outils
numériques et cartographiques qui
permettent d'avoir des visions de des
villes avec je sais pas si vous avez vu
un
pas seulement avec les passements avec
les caméras pas seulement avec les
caméras thermiques mais c'est vraiment
avec tous les DPE déjà connus
ils ont ils ont cartographié et c'est
vraiment un outil remarquable d'abord
parce que c'est aussi ce qu'on faisait
tout à l'heure quand plusieurs voisins
ont déjà vendu et on fait le DPE et tout
ça a été recollé à la fois par la dame
et le cscb et ça donne déjà une belle
indication d'un certain nombre de
territoires sur le niveau des étiquettes
et une connaissance de la ville donc je
continue à penser que le DPE est un
outil extrêmement intéressant pour
mesurer comme ça a été indiqué tout à
l'heure par vous
l'évolution de de nos villes et et
l'évolution vertueuse en amélioration
énergétique
juste une question complémentaire ce que
j'ai donc en lien avec ça c'est que avec
le DPE je pense que va aussi la question
du carnet de santé ou du passeport du
bâtiment et ça aussi enfin du coup le
fait d'avoir à chaque fois une
visibilité sur le classement du bâtiment
les travaux qui ont déjà été faits les
travaux qui restent à faire et que et
que du coup ça suive en tout cas la vie
du bâtiment permet aussi à la fois sur
la question des fraudes mais aussi
d'avoir cette visibilité sur l'avancée
des travaux et d'avoir plutôt ce
parcours justement vers de la rénovation
globale aussi oui
je trouve que c'est c'est une bonne
méthode d'avoir ce
carnet de santé de du bâtiment comme un
certain nombre
d'organismes le propose je pense que
c'est au fur et à mesure qu'on va
avancer de la somme des diagnostics
je crois qu'on va qu'on arrive pas très
loin de Saint-Louis
surtout sur la filière bâtiment parce
que il y a plusieurs préoccupations
est-ce qu'on a évalué quels étaient les
filières qui pouvaient être
consolidés pour du made in France qui
rend clair dans l'ensemble de nos
filières qui vont se développer avec la
réhabilitation notamment les poils et
biosourcés etc comment on peut organiser
le développement de vrais filières mais
d'une France et de filières locales en
fonction des qualités possibles de
chaque territoire la deuxième étant
aussi l'observatoire des prix car on
sait que tendancellement quand on
subventionne
telle est-elle mécanisme on observe
quand même assez souvent en corrélation
une hausse des prix qui quelque part
s'adapte à la subvention de la demande
on l'a observé dans pas mal de
est-ce qu'il y a une observatoire
peut-être avec la DGCCRF qui permet
d'évaluer l'évolution des prix alors on
va nous dire les matières premières
augmentent etc mais on l'a vu sur les
fenêtres quand il y a eu l'aide aux
fenêtres et une augmentation du prix des
fenêtres qui avait rien à voir avec la
guerre en Ukraine etc donc cette
deuxième c'est un comment on fait des
filières françaises j'ai vu que le
gouvernement semblait intéressé sur les
pompes à chaleur comme on parle
d'industrie verte c'est peut-être quand
même un sujet à prendre en compte de
évolution des prix pour que les
subventions ne soient pas absorbées par
artificiellement une hausse des coûts
des matériaux et des produits
alors vous avez complètement raison il y
a plusieurs plusieurs sujets dans dans
votre question d'abord
vous le savez la R20 favorise évidemment
l'emploi de matériaux bas carbone ou
favorisant le stockage du carbone et
puis il y a des objectifs d'utilisation
de matériaux
biosourcés notamment et pour y arriver
l'intérêt c'est de créer une filière la
plus franco-française possible pour pour
répondre à ses besoins
le gouvernement soutient plus nombreuses
années et essaie de développer un
certain nombre de filière notamment la
filière bois qui est toujours toujours
en cours et puis un certain temps
sujet sujet compliqué mais sur lequel il
ne faut pas renoncer
au contraire tout en étant attentif
aux problématiques de construction
de respect des normes incendies etc qui
sont aussi au cœur de notre travaux et
puis voilà et puis sur le l'effet aussi
du
de la construction hors site qui permet
aussi de valoriser ces filières mais
pour y arriver il faut qu'on ait une
production notamment de bois
biosourcés plus importante
en tout cas dans il y a un appel à
projet dans le cadre de France 2030 sur
cette filière bois avec avec Christophe
Béchu et Marc féno on a plusieurs fois
été à la rencontre des acteurs de ces
filières et on croit on croit à son
développement de la mont à Laval et on
va continuer à le faire on a aussi des
sujets autour du béton du béton bas
carbone et là encore des entreprises
françaises sont extrêmement dynamiques
sur cette question là alors avec
des sujets extrêmement techniques de
laitance et de fabrication du béton et
et entre des entreprises françaises et
non françaises chacun à nous expliquer
qui sont le béton le plus bas carbone
possible
c'est forcément les Français qui ont
raison en tout cas je le crois mais en
tout cas on a on a ça et puis vous le
savez on travaille sur un carbone score
un peu sur la méthode du nutriscore si
j'ose dire qui qui va complètement dans
l'esprit de la R20 pour pouvoir avoir et
compléter le carnet de santé de
l'immeuble mais là pour le neuf avoir un
état des lieux et pour les entreprises
de choisir des matériaux plus qu'un
autre en fonction de leur bilan carbone
mais ça nous oblige à continuer à
travailler continuer à structurer la
filière vous avez raison aujourd'hui si
toutes nos pompes à chaleur viennent de
Chine ou de pays asiatiques c'est ça
aurait un effet et il est important mais
je crois que nos grands nos entreprises
y travaillent
dans l'évolution des modes de chauffage
et
et de la baisse des de consommation des
des gaz à effet de serre à être à la
pointe à développer différents packs de
qualité que ce soit pour du petit ou des
grands ensembles immobiliers et aussi
puisque ça a été un sujet sur la
question du confort
d'été même si il faut pas se contenter
de se dire qu'il fera bon parce qu'on
aura fait tourner la pompe à chaleur
pendant tout l'été et qu'on aura
consommé beaucoup de d'électricité c'est
aussi par des moyens passifs qu'il faut
se protéger du soleil
plus de questions et bien écoutez merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre on a fait
le tour avec un arbre c'était très
intéressant
j'ai fait de mon mieux et s'il y a des
manques revenez vers nous
notre rapport en commission d'enquête la
fin du mois de juin et
la publication officielle première
semaine de juillet voilà voilà bonne fin
de journée à tous